out of all the personalities you sat
down with who who is like the one where
you would say this guy
you know if he wanted to he could be a
president out of all the person you've
met with a lot of Leaders with strong
personalities have to be strong
negotiators processors who's that woman
if this guy ran I think he would win
well not not now but in his day
um I think he would have been a great
president he was in my firm for a number
of years Jim Baker he had been secretary
of state Secretary of Treasury Chief of
Staff under Ronald Reagan 12 years on on
blemished record practically in federal
service he's now 93 or 94 not obviously
going to be running for president but he
was an incredible person was in our firm
for quite some time and I I really
admired him
um and did you read his book did you
read he there's a book written about him
thousand Pages book 1100 page book well
his the book he wrote right after he
left
um I did read it but he wrote a second
book which I found better which is more
about politics and so forth the second
book I enjoyed more the the book that's
written about him
um the man who ran Washington that's the
one I couldn't put it down the Peter
Baker yeah yeah Peter Baker wrote his
with his wife with his wife that book is
uh that book's a really good book and
and I think it's a really good read on
how Washington works and how one man who
didn't have a real history in Washington
wasn't really a politician he came to
Washington because his best friend
George Bush was helping get a job there
and all of a sudden
um yeah he became very very prominent in
Washington did a great job as chief of
staff from Ronald Reagan considered the
gold standard to be Chief of Staff you
go on record saying that you're the
greatest American is in the greatest
president is Abraham Lincoln there's no
doubt about it what is some of those
personality traits do you think that
could be adaptable in today in 2022
um Abraham Lincoln held the country
together at that time most people would
have said the South you want to go away
go away because you know it wasn't easy
to say we're going to fight a civil war
of this in part because the truth is the
Civil War was not fought by the north to
uh free the slaves that wasn't the
Israel Mission it was to hold the union
together later he did the Emancipation
Proclamation which was done as a war
measure to help him win the war because
he was going to have 200 000 black
soldiers fighting for the union which he
did and ultimately helped win the war
Abraham Lincoln had a number of great
qualities but one of them was one we
haven't talked about which is humility
Abraham Lincoln didn't go to forge
theater the night before he was asking
and say you know what I won the world I
won the Civil War how am I great how
great am I um he didn't brag about
himself he had a lot of humility and I
think humility is a is a great virtue
and he had a lot of self-deprecating
humor uh that he would bring to the case
you know he would say you know people
say I'm two-faced well if I had two
faces why would I wear this one because
um he had a he had a he was the person
who held the country together there's no
doubt that the country would not have
stayed together without Lincoln most
politicians would not have done what he
did so I think he was the greatest
American when he became a president you
know was it a Buchanan uh
so he would say listen slavery is
something I'm going to work with and go
with he was kind of looking forward to
just like the same thing yeah see the
13th amendment abolished slavery uh that
came about at the end of Lincoln's
tournament right it was passed by
Congress a couple days before he was
assassinated but in the uh when James
Buchanan who was uh you know not a great
president maybe one of her weakest ever
he supported something called the Corwin
Amendment which was the 13th Amendment
as it was intended to be that said
slavery is the law of the land and don't
it can't be changed in the in the
existing states that have it Lincoln in
his inaugural address the first one he
endorsed that because he thought he had
to make it clear to people in the South
look I'm not trying to get rid of slaves
that I I just don't want slavery to be
expanded to the other states the western
states but in your States it's in the
Constitution we're going to keep that
and Lincoln said that and there's an
inaugural address now obviously evolved
over a period of time but Lincoln was
not an abolitionist by far he was not
there were many people who wanted to
abolish slavery he was not one of them
and what's your favorite Lincoln book
I think the uh probably well I think
that John Nation one is really good but
Doris Karen's good when uh the Team of
Rivals which was made into the Lincoln
movie yep is is a spectacular book but
she you know there are 10 000 books on
Lincoln and I asked Eric Clarence
Goodwin why did you think the world
needed another one but she came up with
a novel concept that Lincoln was so
secure that he took people who were his
Rivals for the uh for the presidency and
he put them in the cabinet and and they
ultimately they became people who had
initially thought he was nothing but now
they became to admire him greatly do you
think there'll be a time where we'll
have a Republican president and a
democratic VP or a Democratic president
and a republican VP you think because I
think it happened one time what was the
year when a candidate had a opposing
party VP that they're running with there
was somebody that happened this and by
the way this wasn't too long ago this
was like 50 60 years ago 70 years ago
you think we'll have that ever happen
um it's hard to see because right in the
old days the original way the
Constitution was originally set up
whoever had the most votes for president
got got to be president whoever the
second most became vice president we've
changed the Constitution so that
probably is harder to do now but look
maybe to get a unified ticket somebody
you could do that but on the other hand
the vice president doesn't have that
much power relative to president so I'm
not sure the the vice president's party
would think it's a good consolation but
nothing's impossible who could say
what's impossible so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]